[Music]
with resident evil village just around
the corner it got me thinking about
another resident evil game with villages
in it and oh yes
i'm talking about that one it's one of
the most influential games
ever made it innovated the third person
action genre it reinvented
survival horror as we know it and above
all else
it's been boarded 11 times i would know
because
i've bought it four times
[Music]
make it five and see it's kind of absurd
to think that i've
purchased it that many times not just
because i have a problem but
because it was only supposed to belong
on one console in the first place
the gamecube however there's a piece to
this whole thing i
didn't remember i was talking to my
co-producer chris morris and i was like
isn't it crazy that resident evil 4 is a
gamecube exclusive and he was like yeah
it was a part of the capcom 5. and i was
like what it was this deal capcom had
with nintendo to make exclusive games
for the gamecube and capcom just stabbed
them in the back
i was intrigued
so first what is the capcom 5
18 years ago three years before rezzy
even graced this planet in 2002
capcom announced this big old
partnership with nintendo deemed the
capcom 5.
the press release read new five titles
for
nintendo gamecube piano 3 beautiful joe
dead phoenix killer 7 and lastly
resident evil 4. now with the exception
of resident evil 4
all these other titles were completely
new ips
and their development would be overseen
by shinji
makami who was basically like mr
resident
evil man he's a big deal in fact this
whole thing
was a huge deal we're talking one of the
biggest companies in gaming with one of
its biggest names
shinji mikami making five games
four of which were completely new
exclusively
for the gamecube nintendo fans were
excited
like this dude chris scullion writer of
both the nintendo and super nintendo
encyclopedia
as a big kind of gamecube fan i was at
that point i was already starting to get
quite
concerned and frustrated that third
parties weren't supporting nintendo i
mean i was used to it because nintendo
64 went through the same thing
so when the capcom 5 were announced my
initial thought was
yeah i mean obviously not only was
nintendo getting
five brand new games uh the gamecube was
also
getting like five what could potentially
be fantastic exclusives
the gamecube was going to have more
stuff that was kind of uh
exclusive to and gave it someone kind of
little character in its own personality
for any console not just a gamecube this
would have been a big deal
but it was especially so for the
gamecube
first it was not selling well now
despite being a more powerful system
than the ps2
its power wasn't enough to make up for
the fact that it was not
a multimedia device it could not play
cds
or dvds like the ps2 or xbox
two it did not have great third party
support aside from nintendo's usual
suspects
there wasn't a whole lot of support or
exclusives
for the gamecube and though its flagship
franchises were enough to keep it afloat
there wasn't much support to attract a
broader audience
or to be really specific it didn't have
guns
blood or butts now it's not
scientifically proven but from what they
hear
it can remedy success according to me
anyways
as it would churn out the capcom 5 had
all of it
if capcom could produce five very good
games that appealed to a broader market
than just mario and zelda lovers
it would do two major things for
nintendo
push console sales up and show
third-party developers that abandoned
nintendo during the n64
that it was cool to work with them again
because they were down with guns blood
and butts and
all the meanwhile capcom would just ride
the wave of success
however there was a minor communication
error so
the us press release alluded that all
the games would be gamecube exclusives
but
the japanese press release said
otherwise
as it turns out capcom would be
developing these five games
first and foremost for the gamecube
with the possibility of them being
ported
in the future but that's okay because
the most anticipated one of them all
was absolutely a hundred percent
definitely going to be a gamecube
exclusive
there was even a limited edition
gamecube just for it look at this look
oh there it is it was no different than
any other gamecube and you're damn right
i wanted it so
one by one the capcom 5 came out as
promised with the first one being in the
butts category
piano three which apparently folks
weren't too
crazy about or like piano three out of
ten
it's not my joke co-producer chris gave
it to me
thanks chris then there was dead phoenix
which just was
straight up canceled never came out
living right up to its name but
beautiful joe did come out and it was
great and had some success
on the gamecube until it was ported to
the ps2
and in that moment it seemed pretty
clear that capcom was losing faith
in the very plan that it set forth on
but
there was still resin before the chosen
one the one sworn
to exclusivity for the gamecube director
shinji mikami himself
said he would cut off his own head
before his ported to other consoles
[Applause]
and so gamecube fanatics held on to it
it was the cover story for
several nintendo publications previews
were praising it
it was easily the most anticipated game
of 2005
and to top it off it was the most
unnintendo game possible it was super
violent
hyper detailed and had its own blood
splatter controller
to prove it even had his own website
resident evil controller dot com
and then two months before the game came
out capcom
sent this press release which read
capcom's million selling series resident
evil
expanding to the nintendo gamecube and
the sony
playstation 2. there was a few years
into the gamecube's life at this point
people were thinking this isn't
this isn't going well but at least we
were climbing at the fact that don't
worry this game looks
great and we're going to have a great
game just as the gamecube is kind of
flat line and we've got this great one
and we will we'll always have that we
can cling to that and then obviously a
couple of months before it came out
capcom said nah
we can't let that happen this is coming
we're not even giving you that it's
coming to playstation 2
purely in terms of financial reasons
they had to kind of expand and say okay
sorry we know we promised these were
exclusives but now they're coming to
playstation 2 as well because
money we've got we've got to sell these
things and we've got to get make sure
more people can see them gamecube
fanatics were
well less than thrilled so much so that
they sent
letters in to magazines at the time you
know but because
that was back in the day before people
just flooded comment sections
now for what it's worth the nintendo
gamecube did have exclusivity on the
game for most of 2005 until
it came on the ps2 towards the end of
the year
and as history has told it's been
regaled as one of the greatest video
games of all time being ported from
everything to the nokia phone
to the zebo selling over 10 million
copies across the 67 some platforms it's
been ported to
and shinji mikami is still alive and
well he never caught his head off he
just left capcom instead and formed
platinum games
nintendo on the other hand well some
speculate that
it left them bitter jaded stabbed in the
back that was their hope to bring life
to the console it's even circulated that
this is all the very reason in which
mega man and street fighter characters
were not in super smash bros brawl
a game that featured third party
characters like snake
from metal gear solid strangely though
is that most people that worked on the
capcom 5 eventually found their way
back to being nintendo exclusive
developers
like suda 51 who directed killer 7 is
now making no more heroes 3
exclusively for the nintendo switch then
there's platinum games
which a lot of those the people who work
at that studio worked on beautiful joe
are now developing banana three as
nintendo switch
exclusive so all the roads
somehow led back i can understand how
nintendo would have been annoyed at
third parties for not supporting the
gamecube that much
but i also don't really feel like they
had much say in the matter it's not as
if
companies were suddenly saying actually
we'd like to make gamecube games now and
nintendo saying no no no no
you had your chance i wonder how much of
it is the case of nintendo
genuinely having a grievance against
these companies
or whether it was just in case of them
being hurt and not being able to do much
about it because until their systems
were popular we weren't really going to
have much
interest anyway and capcom seems to have
kind of repaired relationships a bit now
that
ryu and ken and megaman are on smash
brothers and there's more monster hunter
games coming
next year on the switch it looks like
things have finally been patched up
and that gives me a warm feeling in my
tummy
[Music]
now it's kind of impossible to think
what would have happened if
resident evil remained a nintendo only
franchise
would shinju mikami still be at capcom
instead of going to start planting on
games would rez evil 5
or 6 be multiplayer games i don't know
but what i do know is that leon kennedy
would have been invited to fight
in the super smash bros tournament and
chris redfield would have never ended up
punching a boulder and i don't know if
i'm willing to give up one
for the other now looking back
and learning about this whole thing if
there's anything about the capcom 5's
legacy that i find
extremely interesting is that this whole
thing
was an enormous risk for a company like
capcom to make to make these games
new ips for what was a fleeting console
so
i have to give a tremendous amount of
merit to capcom for
at least trying something different even
though it clearly didn't pan out the way
they
intended as for resident evil 4 i'm sure
it would have received the exact same
praise if it had come out for anything
else but its legacy
is all the more interesting to look back
on knowing that it was supposed to
be a nintendo only video game
lastly it's worth remembering that
capcom did fulfill its promise to some
degree
as one of the five games is still an
exclusive for the gamecube
it's just a matter of whether or not
anybody
ever wanted it in the first place
[Music]
hey if you made this far thanks for
watching this episode of remember when
now if you're new here we made a bunch
of other episodes you could check out a
playlist for those
in the description below once again i'm
kurt
pleasure to meet you pleasure to see you
again let me know if you enjoy this
episode
you can leave a comment i'll be there
commenting back okay
from myself and the rest of the team
you're great be great
keep being great be the best you can be
i gotta go
okay see you later and
had its own blood splatter controller to
prove it
i actually did did i actually kill all
those dudes while doing that
gets me every single time